[Music]
a train squeezes through this 500 meter
stretch of railway just west of bangkok
about six times a day
and every time hundreds of shopkeepers
who set up a market directly on the
tracks have to put away their tents
produce and merchandise to make way
for locals it's business as usual at the
mike long railway market even when the
train is so close
tourism is picking up again as thailand
eases its covet 19 entry restrictions
more people and money is a welcome
change
the pandemic led to a huge drop in
customers it was drastic those who
visited bought less than usual so i only
managed to make a third of what i made
before covet 19.
before the pandemic thailand saw nearly
40 million visitors a year now the
government is hoping for 15 million
despite the drop tourism can bring in
roughly 18 billion dollars into the
economy
to attract more people the market has
safety measures in place
when we sound the horn the vendors know
they must clear their stalls off the
rail track everyone is safe because the
train slows down so it's not coming at a
full speed it cruises through the market
slowly
from inside the train it's locals who
are cruising through seeing how
foreigners once again flock to the
market
it's been around since 1905. shopkeepers
say tradition is part of the attraction
years ago vendors only use umbrellas not
tents there was no electricity or water
in the market then more people started
to visit so the number of vendors also
increased
as the government tries to rebuild its
tourism industry leaders hope foot
traffic in this market will be part of a
wider trend across thailand
katya lopes
al jazeera